so let's talk about Shenmue 3 the third
of the oh my god I can't believe they
did that but a little bit they would
like to make this game we're not gonna
fund it you guys can just I think it was
a great springboard for the Kickstarter
yes certainly so they haven't like gone
into details about what this means yeah
right the big rumor that was going
around was that there would be a
Kickstarter and then if it actually made
it what they its goal that then Sony
would front the rest I mean that 2
million dollars is what they asked for
that is not enough no it's not to make a
game so Sony may not have said it yet
but clearly someone else is getting
involved too like this is gonna
overshoot 2 million dollars by a
significant amount but I still don't
think it's gonna be enough to fully fund
a game like Shenmue 3 in the way that
they want to make it and the way that we
want to play it so if my if I had to bet
I'd I reckon that Sony will still cough
up some cash for it and we're yet to
confirm that he hasn't said anything on
it or explained it this is gonna blaze
past its calling so like I mean the game
development are now in the hundreds of
millions yeah for like you know most
modern-day games so it's gonna take a
lot more than most kick starters yeah I
mean if it reaches hundreds of millions
then it's probably gonna be the craziest
kicks off all time well yeah it's it's
good to see it's finally out but that is
what a lot of games are doing on
Kickstarter now just while we started
this yeah I you know with the
Castlevania garages Castlevania
announcement he straight-up said listen
I have backers that are providing 90% of
the funding for this game they just need
like the it's the show of faith like
it's the proof of an audience that
Kickstarter provides and so maybe that's
more of what this is you know if it's a
drop in the bucket of the game design
budget it's proof that people want it
and if judging judging from the reaction
of folks at the Convention Center and
also here Shenmue 3 is something that
people are really I've done I'm not
surprised I reckon Sony will get
probably I mean it's it's a way
win scenario if it reaches his
Kickstarter because I mean fans of the
classic this is everything they've ever
wanted and for Sony they can just start
cranking up the marking machine to
present it as a new IP to people who've
never played it before like this is a
game that's got so much lineage and
heritage you should check it out that
kind of thing so if Sony does get
involved it's it's in their benefit and
for the rest of us we get to play
Shenmue free if it sucks because it
wasn't it's out of the way a better time
cuz most of Europe's asleep right now
except for the clever people who stayed
up to watch this good by the time
everyone watches this on-demand on
GameSpot calm that thing's already
funded yeah yeah yeah it's going at an
incredible pace the Shenmue 3
Kickstarter up announced at press
conference here at e3 2015